[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
الجوانبه
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
البرهان يظهر خارج مقر القياده العامه
لاول مره منذ الاشتباكات ومستشار الدعم
السريع يقول ان حميدتي مستعد للقاء مباشر
اردوغان يصف عدم قدرته على تغيير المعارضه
بفشله الوحيده وكليتش دار اوغلو يرفع ورقه
طرد اللاجئين لجذب الاصوات
وانتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا
اليوم اصحاب مره منذ 12 عاما تمثيل عربي
كامل في اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه العرب
تحضيرا لقمه جده
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
محادثات سقف الدين المتعثره تصب في مصلحه
الصين بايدن يلغي زياره تهدف لابعاد دول
المحيط الهادئ عن بكينه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لاول مره منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات
في السودان بين القوات المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع تظهر لقطات لقائد الجيش
السوداني الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
لاول مره في الشارع
ظهر البرهان محاطا بالعشرات من جنود الجيش
بالقرب من مقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه في الخرطوم يحمل الرجل الرجل
سلاحا اليا من طراز كلاشنكوف على ظهره وفي
جانبه مسدس شخصي كما يبدو انه فقد الكثير
من وزنه بتحليل مقاطع الفيديو التي ظهرت
يبدو انه تم التقاطها هنا في النقطه التي
نراها في هذه الخريطه اي في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش في الخرطوم والتي لا تزال
تشهد اشتباكات منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل
الماضي حيث اظهرت الصور وجود مبنى القياده
العامه المحترق خلفه كما اظهرت الصور صور
اخرى
تجوله بالقرب من مقر قياده القوات البريه
ويبدو ان الرجل التزم بتصريحاته التي ادلى
بها للعربيه قبل ثلاثه اسابيع حين اكد انه
موجود في مقر القياده العامه ولن يخرج
منها الا على نعش فيظهر الان بالفعل في
مقر القياده العامه
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
افتح افتح
[موسيقى]
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
قبل ظهور اليوم لم يظهر البرهان الا ثلاث
مرات منذ بدايه الاشتباكات وجميع ذلك كان
في غرف مغلق الاول حينما ظهر اثناء عمله
في غرفه العمليات ثم التهنئه بعيد الفطر
والمره الاخيره اثناء حضوره الاجتماعات
قيادات عسكريه
[موسيقى]
البرهان اذا ظهر اليوم هو ظهور مكثف على
ما يبدو اما منافسه قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقله فلم يظهر منذ
بدايه الاشتباكات الا مره واحده فقط وكان
ظهورا مقتدما للغايه
في الاثناء قال مستشار قائد قوات الدعم
السريع لشؤون السياسيه يوسف عزت بان حماتي
مستعد للقاء البرهان في اي زمان ومكان
يختاره الوسطاء بشرط وقف اطلاق النار
مشيرا في نفس الوقت الى ان الدعم السريع
سيطر على نحو 90% من مناطق الخرطوم وبان
الحرب الدائره تخللها عمل دعائي كبير من
قبل الطرف الاخر ونفاعه على هامش لقائه
برئيس جنوب السودان الاخبار المتداوله
بشان استخدام الدعم السريع المواطنين
كدروع بشريه
وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من القاهره
المحلل السياسي السوداني عمار عوض اهلا بك
سيد عمار يعني للمره الاولى يظهر عبد
الفتاح البرهان وسط جنوده مادلالات هذا
الظهور في هذا التوقيت بالذات
السلام عليكم اعتقد ان ظهور الجنرال عبد
الفتاح برهان اليوم بهذا الشكل هو يعطي
جمله من الاشارات الاشاره الاولى ان منطقه
محيط القياده العامه بما في ذلك مطار
الخرطوم او المنطقه الحيويه انها اصبحت
تماما في قبضه الجيش وان ليس هنالك من
خطوره عليها كما ان هنالك شواهد بان
المعارك التي كانت تاتي في نشرات الاخبار
في محيط القياده العامه
تراجعت كثيرا
وهذا الخروج دليل من الرجل على ان الامر
لم يعد مثل السابق الدلاله الثانيه هي
رساله ايضا ربما تفهم الى انها الى جامعه
الدول العربيه التي بدات اجتماعاتها
واعتذر هو عنها وارسل موفدا عنه هذا
الظهور ايضا رساله للزعماء العرب لانني
مازلت موجودا وانني مازلت رئيسا لمجلس
الزياده ورئيسا للسلطه الموجوده في
الخرطوم ايضا ظهور الجنرال برهان سبقه في
الايام الماضيه هي تحركات من قبله يبدو
انها كانت ممهده لهذا ظهور عندما قام بما
يعرف بالرنين ستيت اي اداره الدوله وظهور
بمظهر رئيس الدوله عندما قام باغاله وزراء
وقالت دبلوماسيين وغيرها من المفاوضين من
قبل الجيش الذين كانوا موجودين داخل الدعم
السريع الذي قام باحالتهم للتقاعد ظهور
الحكومه في مدينه بورسودان وتوجهوا بهذا
الظهور اليوم لكن عملياتيا اذا نظرنا الى
خارطه العمليات اعتقد انها جنرال البرهان
يبدو انه اصبح في موقف مريح اكثر من
السابق حيث ان ليس هنالك معارك كبيره تذكر
او دعونا نقول هنالك معارك لكن في نفس
الوقت ليس هنالك سيطره او استيلاء على
اراضي معينه شاهدنا في منطقه الكادرو يدخل
الدعم السريع يعود الجيش مره اخرى في
منطقه جنوب الخرطوم يدخل الدعم السريع
يعود الجيش مره اخرى تتحدث التقارير ايضا
على انحسار دائره العمليات في مناطق كثيره
في ولايه الخرطوم او انحصارها الان في
مدينه ام درمان ولكن هنالك تخوفات من انت
هذا الصراع حيث يشاهدنا معارك في مدينه
الابيض وذلك يمكن ان يفهم منه ان قوات
الدعم السريع خرجت من الخرطوم وفي طريقها
الى دارفور او تريد ان تتموضع في مكان اخر
وايضا هنالك غلق كبير من الصراع الذي يدور
منطقه الجنينه المتاقمه
مستشار قائد قوات الدعم السريع للشؤون
السياسيه يوسف عزت يقول بانه حماتي مستعد
للقاء البرهان والتفاوض باي مكان وزمان
شرط وقف اطلاق النار كيف يمكن وصف هذا
التصريح او الرساله هل هو تراجع لقوات
الدعم السريع مرتبط كما وصفته ربما تراجع
على الارض
نعم اعتقد ان قوات الدعم السريع يمكن الان
انها تبحث عن حلول خارج الميدان او خروج
خارج الخرطوم دعونا نقول ذلك او خارج
السودان الحديث حول وقف الاطلاق النار
هنالك منبر موجود في مدينه جده تشارك فيه
الولايات المتحده السعوديه وهنالك زخم
اوجدته الجامعه العربيه بالتالي اعتقد انه
من غير المفهوم ان يربط وقف اطلاق النار
بلقاء ما بين برهان ومحمد حمدان لقاء
مباشر ذلك يعني انه خارج السودان ذلك يعني
السماح لمحمد حمدان بالخروج من السودان
اعتقد ان ذلك ربما يكون خاضعا لشروط تتعلق
بمستقبل الجيش او مستقبل العمليات وكيف
يمكن ان يؤثر اذا خرج محمد حمدان لكن انا
اعتقد هذه الج ايضا تغرى في محاوله لاحياء
منبر الايجاد بعيدا عن المنبر الذي دعمه
السودانيين ودعمه الوسطاء وهو الموجود في
جده شاهدنا لقاءات في مدينه دبا شاهدنا
تحركات من قبل المبعوثه فولكر مع الاتحاد
الافريقي لمحاوله تحويل الملف من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وذلك ربما يعني
سيناريوهيل اما ان قوات الدعم السريع الان
لم تجد ما تريده في تلك المحادثات
الموجوده في جده وتحاول ان تحرف النقاش
واعادته الى منطقه اخرى او انها محاوله من
اجل اخراج محمد حمدان تحت اي ظل من الظلال
وذلك يعيد الى الاسهال المعركه التي كانت
ما بين سلفاكير ورياك مشار وكيف
مشار من جنوب السودان من اجل لقاء سلفاكير
لكن السودانيين بشكل عام يجب ومن المتوقع
انهم يدعمون بشكل كبير مح ادثات جده
باعتبار انها الطريق الاسلم شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا المحلل السياسي السوداني عمر عوض
حدثنا من القاهره
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
المعارضه في البلاد لا تمتلك مشروعا وان
الفشل الوحيد الذي تسبب فيه هو عدم تمكنه
من تغيير المعارضه على حد وصفه
من الفوز بالجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
وبفارق كبير كلتش دار اوغلو تعرض لضربات
كثيره اكثر مما راينا وكما نقول دائما
مشكله المعارضه بتركيا انها لا تمتلك رؤيه
او برنامجا او مشروعا لقد غيرنا كل شيء في
بلادنا لكن للاسف لم نتمكن من تغيير
المعارضه لكننا نعتقد ان هذه الانتخابات
ستؤدي الى التغيير الذي ينتظره الجميع منذ
سنوات
من جهاته مالك لتشدار اوغلو هجوما على
اردوغان وقال انه لا يجب السماح للعقليه
التي سهل الدخول عشره ملايين مهاجر غير
نظامي الى تركيا بالبقاء لاداره البلاد
مشيرا الى ان حزبه سيقاتل حتى الفوز
بالانتخابات
انا اخاطب الجميع لم نجد هذا الوطن في
الشارع لن نترك وطننا للعقليه التي سمحت
بدخول عشره ملايين مهاجر غير نظامي بيننا
ايها الشباب انهضوا وتخلصوا من ذلك الياس
الذي يخيم عليكم اولئك الذين يحبون وطنهم
سياتون الى صناديق الاقتراع سنقاتل حتى
النهايه وسنفوز بالتاكيد
سباق الرئاسه التركيه التي انطلق يوم
الرابع عشر من مايو لم تكن نتائجه ضيقه او
متقاربه بل تفوق اردوغان على كليتش دور
اوغلو باكثر من مليونين ونصف المليون صوت
هذا التفوق لم يمكن اردوغان بالطبع من
الوصول الى النسبه الحاسمه للفوز والمقدره
بخمسين زائد واحد فصل بين اردوغان وبين
هذه النسبه فصل بينهما اقل من نصف نقطه
مئويه ولكن الكثير قد يتغير اذا
ذهبت اصوات سنان
المقدره باكثر من مليونين و800 الف صوت
لاي من المرشحين حتى اننا قد نرى محافظه
قد صوتت الى كمالك لتجدار اوغلو تذهب الى
اردوغان في الاعاده والعكس ايضا قابل
للتحقيق من ابرز هذه المحافظات نذكر في
الجنوب
حيث تفوق هناك لتشدار اوغلو ب 481 صوتا
فقط بمعنى انها من المرجح ان تنقلب لصالح
اردوغان اذا قرر اكثر من 30 الف شخص فقط
اذا صوتوا لسنان اوغان هناك ان يصوتوا
للرئيس الوضع ايضا قد يحدث في العاصمه
انقره طبعا انقره فاز كليتش دور اوغلو
فيها باكثر من 50 الف صوت ولكن يوجد نحو
ربع مليون صوت في حوزه سنان اوغان هناك
ايضا محافظه اردوغان التاريخيه اسطنبول
التي صوتت
قد تنقلب في جوله الاعاده لنفس الاسباب
اذا بشكل عام ابرز المحافظات التي قد
تنقلب اصواتها لصالح اردوغان هي الاتيه
هاتاي
بديليس دينزيلي
وايضا بالي كثير وانقر واسطنبول كما ذكرنا
اما المحافظات التي قد يخسرها اردوغان اذا
قرر سنان اوغان ان يقف ضده فهي ارتوين او
ارتفين واوساك وايضا
هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من اسطنبول
الدكتور
سمير صالحه الاستاذ وفي العلاقات الدوليه
اهلا بك دكتور سمير يعني ما توقعاتك
للجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات التركيه
وما المحافظات برايك التي يمكن ان تنقلب
وتذهب اصواتها ان كان ليردوغان او
المنافس له
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا يعني طبعا
سيكون هناك معركات
انتخابيه جديده في الجوله الثانيه لكن لا
اتوقع ان تكون بنفس الحماس ونفس الاجواء
التي عشناها في الجوله الاولى في الان
خيبه الامل التي تعيشها المعارضه ما زالت
مستمره حتى الان صحيح انه في الان تصريحات
جديده وفي مواقف تقول انه الحملات ستنطلق
وستبدا لكن على مستوى القواعد الشعبيه في
الطرفين في قناعات يبدو انها بدات تظهر
الى الاعلان انه رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
حدوده اكبر في الجوله الثانيه
المعارضه ما زالت مفككه وهي تلقت خساره في
البرلمان وانه التعويل على سنان اوغان
كعامل يدخل على خط
لعبه التوازنات مساله معقده وصعبه للغايه
سنان او صحيح انه يملك خمسه بالمئه في
الجوله الاولى لكن هذه القواعد التي دعمته
احتمال كبير ان لا تلتزم باي قرار يعلنه
سنان لماذا لانه ولا يملك حزب سياسي صحيح
دخل في تحالف اتى الذي يرشحه
الرئاسه لكن الكثير من الاصوات التي دعمت
سنان اوجان بعيده عن جويه
دكتور سمير هو على ورقه الاكراد
صحيح موضوع حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي اللي
كان في تصريحات اليوم لقيادات حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطيه انها ستستمر في دعم
مرشح المعارضه كمال كلش هذا الموقف
يعني انه ربما يقطع الطريق على اي فرصه
للتفاهم بين كمال كريش
انه بين الشروق الاساسيه كما تتذكرين التي
اعلنها سنان اوجان قبل اسابيع كانت قطع
العلاقه بين حزب الشعب وحزب الشعوب الان
هذا الموقف الجديد لحزب الشعوب يؤكد انه
فرصه كسب عشره بالميه من الاصوات التي
يملكها حزب الشعوب اهم من الرهان على
اصوات مفككه يملكها سنان اوغان هذه هي
عقده اساسيه بالنسبه للمعارضه لكن رايي
الشخصي انه نفس المعادله نفس الازمه
والمشكله ايضا يعاني منها
تحالف الحكم اليوم بات جاه
حواره مع سنان اوغن طاوله السداسيه تقول
بانها تدرس وضع خارطه طريق لمواجهه
اردوغان بالجوله الثانيه
اوراق القوه لدى اردوغان معروفه والنتائج
الجيده التي حققها ان كان بالبرلمان وان
كان بالجوله الاولى ما اوراق القوه التي
يمكن ان تستعملها المعارضه بالايام
القادمه
يعني الاهم ما يمكن ان تتحرك باتجاهي هو
محاوله كسب المزيد من الاصوات للفوز يعني
طرح برامج سياسيه برامج انمائيه اقتصاديه
بعد هذه
سمير هذه الاوراق يعني اليوم تحدث عن ورقه
السوريين فقط يعني وكانها الورقه الوحيده
بيدهم
المعارضه تريد ان تكسب كما قلت لك اصوات
سنان اوجان دون دعوته ودون انضمامه الى
تكتل المعارضه هذه النقطه اساسيه تعول
عليها كانت تعول على كسب اصوات محرم
انجيليوم كان له موقف ايضا محرم انجي قال
انه سيقف على الحياد هل قواعد محرم ايجا
تذهب لدعم المعارضه حتى لو كان المحرمجه
يعني متحفظ على موقفه هذه نقطه ثانيه
ستركز عليها المعارضه محاوله كسب الاصوات
التي
لم تذهب الى صناديق الاقتراع وهي نسبه
غير قليله يعني حوالي 10 11 مليون صوت لم
يذهب الى الصناديق الاقتراع هذا الرقم
الان المهم الذي برايي المعارضه ستحاول ان
تلعبه الى جانب الذهاب الى المناطق التي
كانت نسبه
منخفضه فيها كما اشرت انت ايضا قبل قليل
التوجه الى هذه المناطق محاوله التاثير
فيها اقناع الناخب لكن في النتيجه لا اظن
اطلاقا انه المعارضه قادره في خلال هذه
الفتره الزمنيه القصيره على اجتراح
المعجزات شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور سمير صارحه
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
النيابه السويسريه تطالب بسجن حفيد حسن
البنا على خلفيه الاتهامات بالاغتصاب
وتمويل الاخوه تحت الضغط في فرنسا لتمويل
الجماعه انشطه غير قانونيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت الخارجيه السعوديه
الى الوزير الامير فيصل بن فرحانه التقى
بنظره السوري فيصل المقداد على هامش
الاجتماع التحضيري للقمه العربيه بجده
وبحث معه مستجدات الاوضاع على ساحه
السوريه والقضايا ذات الاهتمام المشترك
وكان وزير الخارجيه السعوديه رحب بعوده
سوريا لشغل مقعدها في الجامعه
وانتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا
اليوم اصحاب السوء والمعالي يمر عالمنا
اليوم بتحديات وصعوبات عديده تجعلنا امام
مفترق طرق تحكم علينا الوقوف صفا واحدا
وبذل المزيد من الجهد لتعزيز العمل العربي
المشترك من اجل مواجهتها وايجاد الحلول
بمناسبه لها لتصبح منطقتنا امنه مستقره
تنعم بالخير والرفاه ان منطقه العربيه
تسخر بطاقات بشريه وثروات طبيعيه تجعلنا
امام تحدي مع انفسنا يفرض علينا جميعا
التنسيق المستمر وتسخير كافه الادوات
الممكنه وتفعيل الابتكار الات عمل الجديده
نابدين خلافتنا البينيه رافضين التدخلات
والخارجيه واضعين نصب اعيننا مصالح دولنا
وشعوبنا من اجل تحقيق نهضه شامله طالما
تطلعت اليها شعوبنا
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل
المقداد في تصريحاته للعربيه ان سوريا لا
يمكن ان تغيب عن اي قمه عربيه
كما جرت العاده السوريه لا يمكن ان تغيب
عن اي قمه
كما قلت لا يمكن لسوريا ان تغيب عن اي قمه
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤول دفاعي امريكي ان نظام الدفاع
الجوي باتريوت عالي التقنيه المقدمه
لاوكرانيا تعرض لاضرار خلال هجوم صاروخي
روسيا على كيف لكنه لا يزال يعمل حيث اشار
الى ان واشنطن تعمل حاليا على تقييم
الاضرار المحتمله التي لحقت بنظام الدفاع
الجوي لكنه رفض الادلاء بمزيد من التفاصيل
وفقا لتقرير لصحيفه وستجون
عشرات الهجمات الصاروخيه شنتها روسيا على
مدن رئيسيه في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا
واوكرانيا تقول انها صدت معظمها وكلمه
السر الدفاعات الجويه الغربيه فطوال فتره
الحرب استهلكت اوكرانيا انظمه الدفاع
الجوي من الحقبه السوفيتي التي حققت نسبه
نجاح تصل الى 80% بضرب صواريخ كروز
الروسيه وصلت دعم الغربي مع مجموعه متنوعه
من منظومه الدفاع منها بطاريته صواريخ
باتريوت الامريكيه قدمتها لاوكرانيا كل من
الولايات المتحده وايضا المانيا لصواريخ
باتريوت الاعتراضيه امكانيه على الاصابه
اصابه طائرات مقاتله عاليه وايضا متوسطه
الارتفاع وصواريخ كروز وبعض الصواريخ
الباليستيه منظومه لا تدافع وحدها عن سماء
اوكرانيا تلقت المزيد من صواريخ الدفاع
الجوي قصيره وم بواسطه المدى من دول
النتوء الاخرى تشمل هذه بعض الانظمه
المتاحه الاكثر تقدما مثل بطاريات ايروس
تي ال الالمانيه التي يصل مدى صواريخها
الى اربعين كيلو مترا وحققت بحسب قاده
اوكرانيين نجاحا بنسبه 90% ايضا من
المنظمات التي تبرع فيها او تبرع فيها
حلفاء اكياف من المنظومات منظومات ناس ماس
الامريكيه ووافق وزير الدفاع الامريكي فقد
تمكنت المنظومه من النجاح بنسبه 100% في
منع الصواريخ والمسيارات الروسيه فضلا عن
المتوفر لاوكرانيا حاليا تعمل الدول
الحليفه على امداد كياف بالمزيد من
المنظومات والصواريخ للوقوف بوجه الهجمات
الروسيه وبحسب مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والدوليه الامريكيه ربما تعمل روسيا على
استنزاف المخزون الغربي وقدره الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه لكن موسكو تواجه على
الجانب الاخر اصرارا غربيا على مواصله دعم
كاف عسكريا
وجعلته الدول الغربيه اولويه لها في
المرحله الحاليه
يجب ان نتذكر مقدار الجهد الذي كلفته مثل
هذه الاسلحه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا مقدار
الوقت والطاقه والحجج والاجتماعات والعمل
الذي سمح لنا ببناء مثل هذا النظام
الدفاعي الجوي هذا عمل هائل واشكر كل من
شارك فيه يوما بعد يوم وشهرا بعد شهر يعمل
فريقنا لضمان حصولنا على حمايه اجوائنا
اعتدنا ان نسمع ان حصولنا على صواريخ غير
واقعيه والان ها هي باتمان
[موسيقى]
ازمه سقف الدين الامريكيه بدات تتجلى اولى
ملامحها الخارجيه بقطع الرئيس جو بايدن
لزياره كانت مقرره لاسيا وجزر المحيط
الهادئ قبل ذلك حذرت وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه جنات يدين هذا الشهر من نفادي
السيوله الامريكيه بحلول الاول من الشهر
المقبل ان فشل الكونجرس في رفع او حتى
تعليق سقف الديون الوصول الى سقف الديون
يعني ان حكومه الولايات المتحده غير قادره
على اقتراض المزيد من الاموال وهو ما
سيقود الى تعثر كبير وتبحث الاداره
الامريكيه مع الكونجرس الطرق الممكنه
لمعالجه مشكله سقف الدين البالغه قيمته 31
تريليون و400 مليار دولار الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن التقى بقياده الكونغرس بمجلسيه
النواب والشيوخ واعتبر بعد الاجتماع ان
عدم الاتفاق بين الجانبين سيكون مضرا
بالاقتصاد الامريكي وايضا المواطنين وقال
ان التخلف عن السداد ليس خيارا مطروحا
ابدا
[موسيقى]
لقد انهيت للتو
مع زعماء الكونجرس بشان مسار العمل للتاكد
من ان الولايات المتحده لا تتخلف عن سداد
ديونها لاول مره فوفقا لوكاله مودز
للتصنيف الائتماني فان اقتصادنا سيصبح في
حاله ركود وما يقرب من ثمانيه ملايين
امريكي سيفقدون وظائفهم في حال حصول ذلك
لقد اوضحت في اجتماع اليوم ان التخلف عن
السداد ليس خيارا ولا ينبغي ان تمنع
الخلافات السياسيه بين الاحزاب الكونجرس
من ايثاء الولايات المتحده بالتزاماتها
فلم يسبق لنا ان تخلفنا عن سداد ديوننا
ولن نفعل ذلك ابدا
على ضفه الاخرى قال رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن
مقارثي ان الاجتماع مع الرئيس بايدن توصل
الى ارضيه مبدئيه للتفاوض بين الاداره
والمجلس
لقد انتهيت للتو من لقاء الرئيس اعتقد ان
الاجتماع كان مثمرا ما تغير هو ان الرئيس
اختار الان شخصين من اداره للتفاوض مباشره
معنا لدينا اطار زمني قصير لمحاوله معرفه
كيفيه الوصول الاتفاق كنت اتمنى ان نصل له
في فبراير اعيدوا واكرر الامر اشبه بان
تمنح طفلك بطاقه ائتمان لكنه يستمر في
الوصول الى الحد الاقصى للبطاقه ويتم رفع
السقف عاما بعد عام ولدرجه لا يمكن تحملها
الا يجب ان ننظر الى كيفيه انفاق اموال
دفع الضرائب
في قلب هذه الازمه داخل امريكا يدعم
الرئيس السابق دون الترام تمسك الجمهوريين
بموقفهم بضروره عدم التنازل اثناء محادثات
سقف الدين رغم انتقادات الديمقراطيين له
بضروره عدم استخدام سقف الدين كورقه
سياسيه
[تصفيق]
على الصعيد الخارجي وكما ذكرنا الغى
الرئيس جو بايدن زياره الى باب وغينيا
الجديده في المحيط الهادئ للقاء قاده جزر
المنطقه والمشاركه في محادثات تتعلق
بالامن الاقليمي لمواجهه نفوذ الصينيه
المتزايده هناك اهميه زياره ببغينيا
الجديده تاتي لانها كانت ستكون اول زياره
لرئيس امريكي في منصبه لهذه الدوله كان من
المقرر ان تستمر زياره بايدن لثلاث ساعات
فقط وتوقيع اتفاقيات امنيه مع الدوله
المضيفه ومع مايكرو ناسيا وفي حال اتمام
الزياره فهي ستكون بعد عام من توقيع دوله
اخرى في المنطقه هي جزر سليمان اتفاقيه
تعاون امنيا مع الصين وحينها اعتبرت
واشنطن ان الاتفاقيه مع الصين ستكون لها
تداعيات امنيه اقليميه سلبيه زياره اخرى
ملغات هي لاستراليا حيث كان من المقرر ان
يلتقي بايدن بزعماء استراليا والهند
واليابان وهي قمه اخرى مخصصه لمواجهه
النفوذ الصيني نعود لقمه باب وغينيا
الجديده واشنطن بوست قالت ان قراره بايدن
سيثير تساؤلات حول مدى التزام الولايات
المتحده تجاه دول المحيط الهادئ في وقت
تتزايد فيه المنافسه بين الولايات المتحده
والصيني في المنطقه وكانت زياره بايدن
الملغات ستكون قصيره جدا لكن الاستعدادات
في العاصمه
نقلت عن محللين قولهم ان الغاء او تاجيل
الزياره سيعطي زخما للقائلين ان الولايات
المتحده ربما تكون شريكا لا يمكن الاعتماد
عليه على المسرح العالمي واشار المحللون
الى ان اصلاح الضرر ممكن لكن على المدى
القصير يوم الخميس الماضي وخلال جلسه
استماع للجنه الدفاع بمجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي ربط وزير الدفاع الامريكي رويد
استون الشان الداخلي بالخارجي وشدد على ان
التخلف عن رفع سقف الدين داخليا سيؤدي
لتعزيز الفكره التي تروج لها الصين
ومفادها ان الولايات المتحده قوه عظمى
مستمره بالتراجع
هناك خطر كبير على سمعتنا ايها السيناتور
ينظر الينا على اننا مصدر استقرار عالمي
واننا دائما ما ندفع ديوننا وهناك عدد من
الاشياء التي نعمل عليها مع الحلفاء
والشركاء والتي من شانها ان تثير
التساؤلات حول مدى قدرتنا على تنفيذ ما تم
الاتفاق عليه ولكن الاهم من ذلك هو ان هذا
سيؤثر على سبل عيش قواتنا ومدنيين واعتقد
ان هذا شيء يمكن للصين او اي شخص اخر
استغلاله
انضم الينا من واش
نطن اهلا بك معنا الليله ناديه يعني اخر
التحديثات بما يخص ازمه سقف الدين ويعني
بايدن قال بانه التخلف عن السداد ليس
مطروحا لكن ما الذي يقوله المراقبون
والاقتصاديون حول هذا الشان
اهلا بك راويه اولا الرئيس بايدن يتعرض
لضغوط كبيره جدا لان الوضع حساس داخليا
وهو على اعتاب حمله انتخابيه رئاسيه
وبالتالي لا يمكن للرئيس ان يتغيب عن
الولايات المتحده لمده سته ايام حتى لو
كانت كل هذه التحضيرات التي تحدثت عنها في
بوبا نيوجينيو وحتى حليف قوي مثل استراليا
ستتضرر نوعا ما من غياب الرئيس بايدن لكن
الضرر الاهم والاكبر بالنسبه لها وهو هنا
داخليا وبالتالي حاول قبل ان يغادر بساعات
ان يطمئن الامريكيين بانه سيكون هناك
اتفاق وهذا الاتفاق سيتم من خلال ممثلين
عينهم البيت الابيض لان يتفاوضوا مع رئيس
مجلس النواب طبعا كبر مقاسي ومع المسؤولين
الكبار في المجلسين النواب والشيوخ لكن
هناك مقوله في الولايات المتحده وهي ان
الامريكيين اصبحوا مدمنين على الانفاق
الحكومي الذي يقدمه الديمقراطيين وعلى
تخفيض الضرائب الذي يقدمها الجمهوريين
وهؤلاء يعني هاتين
النقطتان الاساسيتين لا تلتقيان وبالتالي
على الجانبين ان يقدمات تنازلات هذه من
ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى طبعا
يعني سيكون هناك اثر سلبي على الاقتصاد
العالمي ليس فقط على الاقتصاد الامريكي
الاقتصاد الامريكي يتعافى من ازمه كورونا
ليس من فتره بعيده لديه مشاكل كبيره
بالنسبه للتضخم هناك حديث على ان لا يوجد
هناك سيوله كافيه كما تحدثت وزيره الخزانه
وبالتالي المشاكل التي يواجهها الرئيس
بايدن جمه لكن بالنهايه هي سياسيه بالدرجه
الاولى لانه حزب الرئيس لا يتفق مع
الجمهوريين في الكونجرس وبالتالي دوما
دوما يكون هناك انسداد لاي رب انفراجه
يمكن ان تؤدي الى الوصول الى حل لكن
الجميع يدرك بانه هذا امر مهم جدا للناخب
الامريكي للشعب الامريكي للاقتصاد
الامريكي وبالتالي سنرى تنازل من قبل
الطرفين ربما اوله سياتي من البيت الابيض
لان يكون هناك بالفعل التقاء في وجهات
النظر وعدم الاخلال في في دفع الديون وعدم
رفع هذا السقف حتى لا يتضرر الاقتصادي
الامريكي بالدرجه الاولى والاقتصاد
العالمي والثقه بالاقتصاد الامريكي وربط
الدولار بكل الاقتصاد العالمي الذي يعمل
بالدولار ايضا ناديه انا باختصار اود ان
اعرف هل من سقف زمني للبث في ازمه سقف
الديون
للحكومه والرئيس الامريكي
نعم الموعد القادم هو بدايه شهر يونيو
وبالتالي لديه اسابيع لذلك حرز الرئيس على
ان يقطع هذه الزياره يكون متواجدون وحتى
في غيابه سيكون هناك ممثلين عن بيت الابيض
والكونغرس يتم التفاوض والوصول الى حل قبل
بدايه الشهر القادم شكرا جزيلا لك مديره
مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي
على هذه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
في متابعاتي محاكمه حفيد حسن البنا مؤسس
تنظيم الاخوان طارق رمضان شدد النائب
العام السويسري على ثبات اقوال المدعيه
ضده بارتكاب جريمه الاغتصاب بحقها حيث طلب
الادعاء السويسري انزال عقوبه الحبس لمده
ثلاث سنوات بينها 18 شهرا مع وقف التنفيذ
بحق رمضان بتهمه الاغتصاب في قضيه تعود
لعام
2008 معتبرا ان طارق رمضان تصرف بدافع
تلبيه رغبته مع امراه على حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
المدعيه سويسريه في عمر الاربعين اسمها
المستعار بريجيتا المدعى عليه طارق رمضان
حفيدو حسن البنا مؤسسي جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين
التهمه الاغتصاب
وصل رمضان برفقه محاميه الى قاعه المحكمه
الجنائيه في جنيف للدفاع عن نفسه
تتهمه باغتصابها عام 2008 واخضاعها لافعال
جنسيه عنيفه في احد فنادق جنيفا
لقد كان يهاجمها منذ خمس سنوات ويصفها
بالكاذبه هناك شهود في هذه القضيه وهم
اطباء نفسيون استشارتهم بعد الحادثه بشكل
مباشر ودونوا ملاحظات في ذلك الوقت لاحظ
الاطباء الاجهاد واعراض ما بعد الصدمه ولا
يمكنهم الكذب بشان هذا النوع من الاعراض
رمضان استاذ الدراسات الاسلاميه السابق في
جامعه اوكسفورد يواجه تهما مشابهه في
فرنسا اتهمته اربع نساء بالاغتصاب بين
عامي 2009 و2000 2016 ما تسبب بحبسه عام
2017 لعده اشهر ليوضع بعدها تحت اشراف
قضائي وتقييد حريته وان ثبتت عليه قضيه
بريجيت السويسريه قد يواجه عقوبه بالحبس
تصل الى عشر سنوات
ومن القاهره ينضم الينا احمد كامل البحيري
الباحث في شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه اهلا بك
سيد احمد يعني اذا انياب سويسريه تطالب
بسجن طارق رمضان ثلاث سنوات وهو يواجه
ايضا في فرنسا قضايا مماثله لاربع نساء
بنفس التهمه كيف تقرا ما يواجهه حفيد حسن
البنا مؤسس جماعه الاخوان المسلمين من تهم
تهم الاغتصاب
يعني اعتقد اني هذه الحاله وهي حاله
شائكه جدا وانسانيه جدا وخاصه راح نتحدث
عن حاله عنف مصحوبه باغتصاب
بشكل عنيف كما ادعت في حاله سويسرا هذا
الامر وحتى
الضحيه هي بتريد الاعتراف بالجريمه يعني
ليس فقط هي تريد الحبس لكن تريد كنوع من
انواع رد الاعتبار او ما يمكن في علم
النفس يتحدث عن اعاده التاهيل ما بعد
الصدمه هو الاعتراف الجاني بما فعله في
المجني عليه وهذا ما صرح به المحامي
الضحيه في النيابه سويسريه الان طارق
رمضان هو يواجه هذه القضيه وايضا سيواجه
قضايا الاربعه الاخرى حيث ان هو خرج من
فرنسا باذن من السلطات الفرنسيه لان طارق
رمضان هو مقيد التنقل من داخل فرنسا لانه
متهم في قضيه اخرى فيها اربع ضحايا اخرون
حكم يوم 24 مايو الجاري في قضيه سويسرا
يمكن ان يكون دافع
للضحايا الاخرون في فرنسا بمزيد من
التيقن من احداث هذه الجريمه البشعه سواء
جريمه الاغتصاب او العنف المصاحب لعمليه
الاقتصاد هذا الامر على المستوى القانوني
او الانساني للضحايا لكن على المستوى
السياسي هناك خلفيات كثيره هذا الشخص ليس
فقط هو حفيد حسن البنا ولكن ايضا واحد من
العناصر التي كانت تقوم بتدريس الدراسات
الاسلاميه ولهم الكثير من المؤلفات التي
تخدم العناصر الاسلاميه وعلى راسها جامعه
الاخوان المسلمين ومن ثم هذا الامر يعطي
تشكك كبير جدا لكثير من العناصر المرتبطه
بهذا التنظيم ليس فقط على المستوى السياسي
الواضح او على المستوى الارتباط بالعنف
ولكن هناك جانب اخلاقي ايضا هو على خلاف
ما تظهره هذه الجماعه او بعض العناصر انها
عناصر اسلاميه تريد ان نشر الدعوه
الاسلاميه
ووصولا الى الخلافه الاسلاميه كما يدعون
هذا الامر له تاثير سياسي نعم هناك تاثير
سياسي ليس فقط لكونه حفيد مؤسس جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين ولكن الارتباطه
بتنظيراته بتنظيم جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
والارتباط بتدريس يعني الدين الاسلامي
لانه العربيه السيد احمد انتجت وثائقيا
قبل ثلاث سنوات وهو موجود على يوتيوب تحت
عنوان ضحايا طارق رمضان
وتقول عده ضحايا له بانه كان يعتبر او
يتذرع بالاسلام لاستدراج الضحايا على كل
الاحوال ابقى معنا وفيما له شان بالاخوان
ايضا قالت صحيفه لوفيجارو الفرنسيه ان
فرنسا تضيق الخناق على جماعه الاخوان
مشيره الى انه الى انه نحو 20 صندوقا
تابعا لاوقاف وتبرعات تم تحديدها
باعتبارها مشكوكا بارتباطها بتيار متطرف
فرنسا ليتم التجميد ما يقرب من 25 مليون
يورو في مختلف صناديق الهبات التابعه
للاخوان في البلاد واشارت الصحيفه الى ان
هذه الاموال تم استثمارها بشكل غير قانوني
لضمان تشغيل المنظمات المعروفه بقربها من
الجامعه من جديد سيد احمد يعني
مجرد ان تتخذ فرنسا قرارا بتجميد 25 مليون
يورو تابعه للجماعه هل ترى ان السلطات
الفرنسيه
علمت متاخره
بخطر نهج الاخوان على مجتمعها ام انه
اصوات او كسب اصوات المسلمين بهذه الدوله
كان همها الاكبر
لا انا اعتقد ان هذه الخطوه هي خطوه بدات
فيها سلطات الفرنسيه منذ عامين بشكل جدي
فالحديث حوالين
الصناديق الخاصه بالتبرعات مرتبطه بجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين فتحت هذا التحقيقات منذ
اكثر من عامين توصلت اني من 20 صندوق الذي
تم الاعلان عنه في الصحيفه هناك اربع
صناديق او تمن صناديق بشكل اساسي لا في
هناك ادله بتورط لكن ما ثبت من الثمان
صناديق الجاري التحقيق فيها اربع صناديق
منهم ما تم العثور على ما يخرج من 25
مليون يورو ومنهم مليون يورو في خزينه احد
الاعضاء يعني ببيته
بيتم التصرف بيها بعيده عن الشكل القانوني
المتبع في عمليه التبرعات او الانفاق ايضا
هناك الملف اكبر بكثير جدا من الصناديق
العشرين الموضوع مرتبط ببعض المنظمات التي
تمت اعلان عنها زي منظمه المراه المسلمه
الاوروبيه وايضا الصندوق الكندي هناك بعض
المؤسسات التعليميه زي مدرسه ابن رشد وهي
احد المؤسسات المرتبطه بجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وايضا هناك بعض المنظمات زي
منظمه اتحاد المنظمات الشبابيه والطلابيه
الاخوانيه المسلمين المسلمه في اوروبا
واللي هي بتضم في عبايتها ما يقرب من 33
اتحاد شبابي وطلابي مرتبطين في فرنسا كل
هذه المنظمات ان اعتقد ان هي قلقان هي
جاري التحقيق من السلطات التحقيقات
الفرنسيه ويمكن ان تكشف كثير من الوقائع
المرتبطه بعمليه تلقي التمولات وايضا
انفاق هذه الاموال بعيدا عن رقابه السلطات
الفرنسيه في بعض الاماكن التي يمكن ان
ترتبط باحداث نشر الكراهيه والعنف في
الدخل الفرنسي
فيضانات شمال ايطاليا تتسبب في اجلاء
الالاف ومقتل خمسه اشخاص
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بمذكره توقيف دوليه هكذا
اختتمت خمسه اشهر من التحقيقات الاوروبيه
ضد حاكم مصر في لبنان رياض سلامه بعد
محاولات لحمايته من الداخل ورغم ان فرضيه
عدم تعاون الحكومه اللبنانيه ستزيد من
سمعه لبنان سوءا الا انها تبقى فرضيه
مرتفعه
لم نتمكن من الوصول اليه هكذا كان رد
القضاء اللبناني لنظيره الفرنسي الذي
استدعى رياض سلامه فاين اختفى حاكم مصر في
لبنان الذي لم نتمكن نحن ايضا كصيحفيين من
الوصول اليه خلال مهماتنا الصحفيه
هنا داخل اروقه المصري في المركزي يعيش
الحاكم هكذا يقول اللبنانيون فالمؤتمن على
مدخراتهم غادر منزله منذ ان بدا بعض
القضاه بملاحقته رفض القضاء الفرنسي
الاعذار الواهيه التي اعتاد القضاء
اللبناني على اعطائها فصدرت مذكره توقيف
دوليه لا يعلم حتى الان ما اذا كانت
القاضيه ادرزيه قد ارفقتها بطلب الشاره
الحمراء من الانتربول لكن مذكره التوقيف
ما كانت لتصدر لولا وجود شبهه دامغه
رح يدعي اسباب
الاسباب منا جديه بس رح يستعمل معاهده
الامم المتحده رح يقول لهم لانه حضر
الارضيه قبل وقت الدعوه بنفس الاسباب اللي
دعى عليه القضاء الاوروبي تيقول هو انه
انا عندي اجراءات وادعى قبل ما ينتهي
القضاء الاوروبي يعني مشان هيك رح يقول
انا عندي اجراء قائ مه على نفس الاسباب
القانونيه يلي انتم متدين عليها وفقا
للمعاهد الامم المتحده انا لي حق تابع
المسار وانتم بتعلقوا مساركوا لحتابع
المليحه بعد مذكره التوقيف على اصوات
مطالبه بعزل حاكم المصرف حفاظا على ما
تبقى من سمعه للبنان
الا ان حقوقيين يؤكدون انه كان من المفترض
على سلامه تعليق مهامه منذ اللحظه الاولى
لصدور الاتهامات هو جزء من منظومه متكامله
وهذه المنظومه هيدي المنظومه لازم تعزل
خله لبنان يصير مفلس اقليميا ودوليا ماليا
ونقديا واقتصاديا
والعشرين من الشهر الحالي تعلن برزي
قرارها اما بتثبيت الحجز او رفعه عن املاك
سلمه املاكن لم تحركوا الدوله ساكنا باخذ
صفه الادعاء الشخصي للمحافظه عليها مما
يعني خسائر اضافيه لللبنانيين غنوه يتيم
العربيه بيروت
صوره اليوم هي من مدينه هيروشيما
اليابانيه التي شهدت تفجير اول قنبله ذريه
في التاريخ والان تستعد لاستقبال قمه
مجموعه السبع يوم الجمعه بالقرب من نصب
السلام في هيروشيما وهو المبنى الذي
انفجرت فوقه تماما القنبله النوويه خرج
يابانيون يحتاجون على استضافه المدينه
لقمه مجموعه السبع ووصفوها بالامبرياليه
المحتاجون ايضا رفعوا لافتات تطالب بعدم
التورط في حرب النوويه او الدخول في حرب
مع الصين بينما تركز القمه في الاساس على
مواجهه نفوذ الصيني في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
تصريح اليوم هو لمسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جو الذي دعا الى تحرك
ضد الهند يقول بارل ان الهند تحايل على
العقوبات الاوروبيه على روسيا ويجب اتخاذ
اجراءات صارمه ضدها لبيعها النفط الروسي
بعد تكريره الرد على تصريحات برجاء من
وزير الخارجيه الهندي الذي قال ان حديث
باريل ينمو عن جهل بقرارات الاتحاد
الاوروبي نفسه التي تعتبر ان معالجه النفط
الروسي في دوله ثالثه تجعله نفطا غير روسي
فيديو اليوم من شمال ايطاليا التي اصبحت
مناطق واسعه فيها غارقه بسبب امطار غير
متوقعه الامطار الغزيره تسببت في فيضانات
عارمه ومقتل خمسه اشخاص واجلاء نحو خمسه
الاف من مناطقهم كما قررت السلطات الغاء
سباق جائزه ايميليا رومانيا الكبرى
للفورمولا 1 نهايه الاسبوع وتسببت
الفيضانات الكثيفه في مشاركه قوات الجيش
في جهود الانقاذ
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نكتفي بهذا القدر وننتقل الى الزميله ميس
واخبار الساعه
والمزيد من الملفات مساء الخير مساء الخير
راويه اول ملف في اخبار الساعه لليوم ما
زال الجدل قائم حول استهداف منظومه
باتريوس اوكرانيا تنفي والولايات المتحده
تقر بذلك الموضوع الثاني البرهان يظهر بين
جموع من الجيش وقوات البريه ايضا القمه
العربيه في جده والاستعدادات لها وايضا
السلطات الفرنسيه تحاصر جماعه الاخوان
والمزيد من الاخبار نرجو ان تتابعينا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات